the announcement came sunday 15 years to
the day after drew brees signed his
first contract with the saints
after the dolphins said no thank you
we'll take dante culpepper and erect
knee and give up a second round pick
instead sorry dolphins fans but it's
true drew brees announces his retirement
from the national football league chris
and
when you look at the
schedule the timeline the calendar right
yesterday was really the last day he
could let the saints know because the
saints have to get down to the business
of filling out a quarterback depth chart
and if they're going to keep jameis
winston they got to get on it because as
of noon eastern today he can officially
negotiate a contract with another team
so it worked out perfectly maybe in
hindsight we should have known all along
that's when drew was going to do it
that's what he did had a lengthy face uh
facebook instagram twitter one of those
three posts with the explanation as to
why he was doing it as expected he
retires after all those years in the nfl
was drafted by the charges in the second
round 20 years ago and now walking away
from football as one of the best
quarterbacks of all time
i mean absolute legend that's all you
can really say when you talk about drew
brees you just talk about like that
consistency of perfection i mean
unbelievable career a guy who like you
know always kind of uh outperformed what
you expected him like you always talk
about guys who like get the most out of
their god-given abilities like to me
that's where drew brees he's like the
poster child is one of those guys
work ethic work in the classroom
perfection in the in the way he throws
the football so he can be the most
accurate guy ever the quick decisions
and everything he studied all those ways
i mean you're right first ballot hall of
famer uh great guy
and really you know again
um
just just really the one of the all-time
legends of our sports and
i also think more than that the poster
child for like smaller quarterbacks i
mean that's another thing when i think
of drew brees i'll be he's one of the
the the the barrier breakers of that
discussion oh if you're not six three or
six four and you know built with big
square shoulders and can't stand in
there and throw rifles down the field
you can't be good in the nfl drew brees
is one of the first people in our league
to kind of say no there's other ways to
do this let me show you how and that's
where he's really special
think back to 2001 the chargers held the
first overall pick in the draft they did
the unexpected trade with the falcons
allowing atlanta to jump up and take
michael vick right the chargers dropped
down to five i believe it was where they
picked up ladainian tomlinson from tcu
hall of famer round two drew brees hall
of famer although not with the chargers
because three years later the chargers
decided to go for the taller more
prototypical philip rivers and it wasn't
long after that that brees left as an
unrestricted free agent of course the
rest is history he wasn't bad by any
means
when he was with the chargers no one
expected him to become what he became if
so the dolphins would have rolled the
dice on a guy who had 20-plus studs in
his shoulder that was injured in his
final game in san diego
and they wouldn't have sent a
second-round pick to minnesota for dante
culpepper and who knows maybe nick saban
would have stayed in miami a few years
longer than he did if he had drew brees
but part of it too is
saban and brees maybe wouldn't have been
the same magic as peyton right and it
worked and it worked as well as any
quarterback coach combination ever has
for all those years chris and you
mentioned the work ethic that's why i
think it was plausible he was going to
come back because of the work ethic
because of the brain because you know
although you don't have the arm strength
well how much arm strength did he ever
have he still could run the offense if
he wanted to that's why when it started
to look like he was thinking about
coming back we took it seriously because
if he wanted to keep playing he could
keep playing well yeah he's one of those
guys first off that you just go well i'm
not gonna doubt him you know i'm not
gonna doubt that aspect of him he's you
know you know continually proved us all
wrong whether it's back to those days
coming out of the draft doing what he
did after he left the chargers and going
to the saints and all those type of
things and yes it's not like the play
was like oh my gosh it's so bad he's got
to retire but at the same point i will
say it's not the drew brees we saw three
four or five years ago the last two
years and it was getting towards that
you know tipping point but either way i
mean what drew brees sean payton have
done in the nfl
i mean we've never seen
just a quarterback
you know quarterback offensive
coordinator head coach combination
with
just that much offensive explosive you
know explosiveness the consistency week
after week you know the able to be
surgical no matter what defense you put
in front of them that to me is where
that marriage is really special and then
sean payton just being able to be that
mad scientist like you're talking about
more plays more this more ideas shifts
formations all of that drew brees could
always handle it and then also save the
offense when sean payton's offense
wasn't there to be had and saved that
way too so really an amazing career it
really is and and you're right mike i
mean yeah he could have probably came
back and played but i'm glad i'm glad
because i i honestly i think it was time
and i think he's had an unreal career
and now we can celebrate it
you were teetering toward explosivity
there at one point i was tell you that
would have been okay i know okay it
would not have rolled off my tongue the
way and i was like wait maybe that
wasn't right so i kind of went i went to
the explosiveness yes
today we have an excuse though this time
change to deviate as we seriously say
good morning it's pft live it's darker
out than it had been
and i had stress dreams all night long
that i overslept and it was all mashed
up into this weird
narrative where i did wake up late and i
was doing the the
the the show and what i sleep in because
i had to run up here actually the camera
was in my bedroom you know all the weird
stuff you have when your brain mashes
together but it was all from the time
change
we were spoiled by the fact that it was
actually daylight
when the show began and now we have to
wait a month or two until it's daylight
again first world problems i know but
man i hate that every year oh it hurts
it hurt waking forward right i mean i
don't know what it was today it didn't
hit me yesterday as much as it did today
where i just was like
whoa
it's time to get up excuse me i mean i
couldn't believe it i was in shock i was
in the deepest sleep ever so uh yeah i'm
awake now but you're right a little
foggier here getting going this morning
maybe compared to other mornings
well today's a day that'll snap us out
of it quickly beyond the drew brees
situation about that more free agency
begins as a practical matter in just
about five hours because that's when
players can
officially begin
fielding offers from teams and striking
deals the teams just can't announce them
they're not done until wednesday at 4 pm
eastern but for all practical purposes
they are done as to breeze though i look
first ballot hall of famer that's a
no-brainer where he fits in the pantheon
of all-time greats
it's going to be subject to dispute yeah
i i i probably put him higher than you
would right there are a lot of great
quarterbacks that have played over the
years his records his moments the things
he's done just by way of compiling
statistics like few ever have yeah and
really but for tom brady he'd be walking
away with all the records right now
brees has been incredible
he broke that dan marino record that
doesn't even show up on the screen of
the top six single season performances
5084 was the record from 1984 until
2011. think about it with the
proliferation of the passing game and
then it was breeze breeze breeze breeze
and you see peyton manning and tom brady
on there as well 5000 used to be largely
unprecedented it's become somewhat
routine and breeze is the guy who shows
up with more 5 000 yard seasons than
anyone else and he really did compile
statistics and achievements like no one
else he has the super bowl win i know it
it tormented him to not get a second one
and that was another thing that may have
caused him to think about giving it one
more run after seeing what tom brady did
this year but one one is good enough
fran targanin dan marino dan fouts
will tell you
one is good enough drew you didn't need
a second one and he's getting into
canton with the accomplishments even
without the super bowl championship but
at least they got that and it came at a
perfect time three years after the
rebirth of new orleans three years after
his arrival in new orleans and then they
spent the next decade or so trying to
duplicate it and we're still contenders
most of the time there were some seasons
where they were hovering just just under
500 and the offense was still great it
was the defense was abysmal there's
never been a question with the offense
in new orleans not since brees arrived
no it's been he's been
i mean they've really been relevant ever
since brees and sean payton have been
there you're right i mean yeah there was
a little of course the the bounty gate
and those years that threw them off
kilter a little bit and they weren't
maybe the same quality football team but
as soon as like that got you know that
ship got righted there
it was okay wow and they made some
second run here you know like you said
disappointing they never got to a super
bowl or won another one yeah sure
certainly uh they were one of the better
teams in football but regardless you go
through the 2000s there you know from
2006 to 2010 you know it was
the saints watch out ooh if they get in
the playoffs they can make a run and
then yes we went through that time
period but man what a run really the
last five six years to go along with it
and the numbers are they're
mind-boggling they're mind-boggling all
the yards the touchdowns and of course
he will forever be known for mr
completion percentage too and that's the
the biggest thing just the efficiency in
which he
moved the ball kept his offense in great
situations did all those things uh
that's what i'm always gonna remember
drew brees and
despite like
you know that narrative that you said
like oh you know he never had a big arm
and all that you know when you go back
and watch drew brees highlights though
i mean the physical ability is real that
that's one thing like it's we're talking
phenomenal athlete we're talking he
could have played professional tennis
and and really probably made waves there
right i mean uh and then you talk about
his athleticism within the pocket but
even the arm yeah okay maybe it's not
one of the great arms of all time but i
know when i go back and watch old
highlights of him i still go damn his
arm is better than we gave it credit for
we give it credit for right now at this
point of his career in his prime he can
make every throw you needed for sure and
he was a great athlete and you know
between that the yards the completion
percentage
he's the guy that everybody looked at to
be like
for the quarterback world let me watch
drew brees to get my technique in order
that's really what he was and even for
coaches it was like let's show drew
brees film to our young quarterback look
how he keeps his base look where he
keeps his shoulders look how he keeps
the placement of the football look how
he goes through the reeds and with each
reed his feet marry his brain and his
eyes and where they go and he really
became like the teaching tool for that
that you know aspect of playing the
quarterback position and that to me is
part of his legacy as well mike it
really is amazing when you think about
those 5 000 yard seasons which have
become not quite commonplace you're
throwing an extra game most likely
starting this year and they will be more
common when brees under the nfl the only
5 000 yard season was dan marino 5084
from 1984 a record that held through the
constant growth of the passing game
right
since then since bree's arrival he's got
it five times now other quarterbacks
have done it peyton manning tom brady
ben rothsberger jameis winston patrick
mahomes matthew stafford no one else has
done it more than once mourinho only did
it once brees did it five times and it
was 2011. that was the year that he
obliterated the record with 54.76 and
then peyton manning by one yard topped
him two years later in denver but uh
just amazing and maybe just a matter of
time until somebody gets to 6 000 yards
again with that 17th game right that's
going to give somebody a shot to do it
but brees showing that production in the
passing game at an obscene level was a
possibility he made it into a reality
and you think about where that saints
team was and you know revisionist
history comes into play because once we
get a narrative that we can wrap our
arms around we forget how things were
2004
2005.
katrina tom benson was looking for an
excuse to move that team to san antonio
right and in the immediate aftermath of
katrina
the nfl made it clear to benson that
team's not going anywhere yeah and the
nfl and the saints became an integral
part of the rebirth of new orleans
culminated on that monday night game the
u2 and green day concert ahead of time
and then the steve gleason block pont
new orleans was back and right you know
it went from a team that was just kind
of hanging around they'd have a kind of
accidental playoff year in their time
yeah and then ever since then 2006 they
went to the nfc championship game i mean
i i can't think of a team that had more
of an abrupt holy crap
from
you know
not bottom of the pack but
bottom third yeah top third and and it
never and that that was it no you're
right they've been the same ever since
been a staple in the nfl ever since i
think you're right mike that's that's
really part of his legacy too the fact
that he is like
you know the king the king of new
orleans really in that aspect you know i
think we all we always used to think of
like archie manning right i think he was
the guy i thought of really you know as
far as a professional sports player when
you when associated with new orleans
and that that's not of course the aspect
anymore like zion williamson first pick
of the draft two years ago well hey
you're here to what you know take over
for king breeze to be the new guy here
in town he is like a staple of the nfl
with what him and sean payton did with
the saints but of course yeah he's truly
the crown jewel of athletes in that city
and you know i i also find cool like you
know we talk about a super bowl right
super bowl's like unreal story it was a
game you know really oh they they're not
going to beat the colts and peyton
manning and you know even within that
beats brett favre you know son you know
uh a guy that's native to that area and
then of course beats one of the kings or
the princes of new orleans and peyton
manning in the super bowl and has that
victory but amazing career and you're
right mike that's another thing it was a
team that occasionally popped off in the
playoff conversation
once every six seven eight nine years
something like that and they've become
one of the consistent powerhouses and of
football ever since drew brees got there
that's that's pretty damn special
and that playoff run started by sending
kurt warner into retirement too right so
three great quarterbacks that had to
take down to climb the mountain and uh
yeah that that super bowl 44 very
memorable had the surprise onside kick
something that we'll likely never see
again in a big spot because they're so
hard to recover now but so many
different things that culminated in that
super bowl championship
and and i
you know i
and it felt like a team that that was
every team that went to super bowl feels
like it's gonna be back again but but
they really did feel like they had
everything that they needed uh but the
next year they they didn't win the
division they had to go on the road to
seattle to face a team that had four
fewer wins and that was where it all
ended they didn't even get past the wild
card round the second year and then came
the bounty scandal and and that was the
the dark years when the defense was
abysmal they were recovering from that
but then they came back strong 2017 18
19 20 had 49 wins in four seasons first
team to have that many wins and not get
back to a super bowl and it's a shame
that the
that the final
chapters
of drew brees career consisted of so
many of these
rip the heart out right and look at it
moments
and yeah whether it was the minneapolis
miracle whether it was the
defensive pass interference debacle
against the rams the the exit in
overtime at home against the vikings
with the touchdown from kyle rudolph
that had a more than a little bit of a
chubby chevy chevy there and uh
you know they because they couldn't they
felt like they wish here they were
destined to get 20 out of 10. they're
driving i mean it's 20 to 10 they're
driving you're going
the bucks are they're in trouble
it's over if they go down you you had
that feel you kind of felt like the
saints were in like yo breezing the
offense got it going there's jared cook
over the middle and you're thinking whoa
and then you know he forgets i don't
know antoine winfield's covering him and
and then there's that fumble and the
game wasn't the same so you're right
mike i mean at the end of his career
that's what we're gonna remember that
aspect uh but we can't forget the aspect
of i mean he dealt a lot of teams
heartbreaking losses throughout his
career too but it's it is it's crazy you
know like you've said the saints were
one of the two or three best teams in
football the last few years and it's
just been one heartbreak after another
that does think for drew brees as far as
his legacy and those conversations
i'd love to know
over the ensuing weeks since that game
because
that that r yeah when you think back on
that moment it was cook catches the ball
he crosses the 50. there we go and they
get 13 they're going to be up 17.
antoine winfield rips the ball out
and devin white scoops it up and and
everything changes
i'd love to know the answer to the
question of how much and and not that
not that i take any pleasure in the
torment that drew brees had to be
feeling but how much was he legitimately
thinking about
giving it another go because of the way
it ended versus just you know the
natural closure there's no rush for me
to announce this let me just take my
time let me let me just let me just ease
my way out of this and hey hey how about
the 15th anniversary of the day i signed
let's just do it then you know let me
push this off as long as i can versus
i really want to come back i really
think that one more run may be the one
and i don't want to spend the rest of my
life thinking man i could have come back
for one more year and we could have
finally punched through and got super
bowl number two and i'll never know now
if that one more year would have been
the one well that's where like that's
where i was going to ask you right
because that's one of the things is you
know you see this news yesterday you
start to talk about it you know or think
about what you're going to talk about
and and those type of things
do you think
over the last few weeks
he was kind of sitting back
still pondering playing
maybe waiting to hear
you know if there was clamoring from the
fans in new orleans and maybe the the
organization would publicly say
something about bringing them back do
you think he was kind of waiting for
some sort of sign or signals just to
leave the door open because you know
like we've talked about the things we've
heard sean payton say
you know yes the saints kind of said all
the right things but i never i don't
think either one of us got the feeling
that it was like oh we want you back we
want you back we want you back do you
think he was kind of waiting for that
and still toying around with that idea
you know here the last few weeks
i think if he was waiting for anything
and this is as you would say reading
between the tea leaves of everything
we've seen and heard and witnessed over
the course of the past year the one
thing you would wait for is a phone call
from sean payton yeah saying i went back
and i looked at the film i think you
still got it let's do it because the
messages from peyton have been
as clear as they can be without him flat
out saying it he's been ready to move on
he was the one who let the cat out of
the bag last year that it's going to be
drew's last year and then he had to
correct himself when drew said ho ho ho
i haven't said anything about it being
my last year and then in the immediate
aftermath of the loss to the buccaneers
sean payton's asked by reporters whether
or not brees is done the report that day
from jake laser that it was gonna be
drew's last game right if they'd lost
obviously and payton says that's an
announcement for a different press
conference well you don't have a press
conference to say you're coming back
so uh and it'll be interesting to see if
they have a press conference
at all there wasn't one yesterday maybe
there'll be one this week the saints are
otherwise going to be occupied trying to
get some things done maybe they'll have
a press conference at some point it's
hard to do the traditional old school
press conference in the pandemic yeah
right now you just have to you have to
wonder you have to wonder you know we
did our
our
oprah interviews last week people we'd
like to see sit down with oprah
sean payton and drew brees get him in a
room together have a couple drinks get
the tongue loosened up a little bit and
find out exactly what went down the
course of the last year wouldn't
surprise me if brees felt like
sean was ready to move on and that's his
prerogative he's the coach of the team
sure but i think i think from our
perspective we thought he was ready to
move on
from drew's perspective
that may have been a big part of it he
may have thought that sean is ready to
move on yeah i mean
i would hard it would be hard to believe
that he wouldn't receive you know those
signals right i mean you know drew brees
is smart enough that for if we're kind
of seeing those signals i would think he
would too to a degree but yeah he was
going to be forced into a corner totally
i guess throughout this process and just
be like told what to do he kind of
weighed made things weight you know made
us all wait made the saints sweat it out
a little bit to a degree and you know
the other thing i'll say to even to that
like right because you know yeah we had
fun with that last week with the oprah
draft and we'd want to see that but i
mean hey
what what quarterback coach combination
really ends that well right in the like
right aftermath right i mean gosh we can
look at them all bill walsh joe montana
what what i got the best one for you tom
brady and bill belichick no no better
than that better than that hits closer
to home who's peyton's mentor who's his
mentor it's bill parcell yeah right was
it was it a positive separation did it
go the way your dad wanted it to go
that's right when it ended no between
parcells and phil sims no well you know
parcels was gone but it was you know
ended up being dead but either way never
mind but don't don't don't don't don't
back
narrative don't
it was a great one forget about truth
nothing about reality none of that
matters haven't we learned anything over
the last five years folks it doesn't
matter what actually happened but that
matters is it a good story it's a real
thing it's a real i mean you're right
it's just you know again yes
quarterbacks coaches okay it never ends
quite like perfectly it's not storybook
there's very few in the history of the
nfl
and yeah okay they're they're probably a
little bit whatever
but they'll they'll mend it together and
then they're gonna realize what a
special run they had those are great
competitors you know and you're telling
one competitor or give them signals like
hey yeah you can't yeah you know we
don't know if we want you all the time
and he's like what well what are you
crazy i could still play and you know of
course they butt heads that way so i i
don't think it's going to be anything of
like a problem going in the future but a
lot of these end this way
how could i forget that great passing of
the baton from bill parcells to ray
handling i know how could you have
forgotten that come on
uh
just like richie pettibone blink and you
missed the entire tenure of the
the bridge after the the great hall of
fame coach
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports